so und jetzt schauen wir auf zwei
Rohrbomben selbst gebastelt und darauf
gut zu erkennen ein Hakenkreuz diese
Bomben die werden am Wochenende am
Bahnhof in straussfurt entdeckt nahe
Erfurt der Bahnhofsbereich wird sofort
weiträumig abgesperrt kein Zug fährt
mehr zwischen Erfurt und Nordhausen ein
Rechtsradikaler Bombenanschlag die Frage
steht jetzt im Raum bildchef Reporter
Frank Schneider zwei selbstgebastelte
Rohrbomben an einem Bahnhof nahe Erfurt
wie gefährlich waren diese beiden
Sprengsätze
erlaubt Ermittler sind sie zündfähig
gewesen was jetzt noch nicht darüber
aussagt wie hoch die zündkraft gewesen
wäre also sie werden beide detoniert die
hatten wohl keinen fern und auch keinen
Zeitzünder sondern während vermutlich
vor Ort angezündet worden und dann
dauert es einen gewissen momentan
entfernt sich dann eben dieser Täter und
dann können die explodieren wie viel
wuchtiger habt hätten muss man abwarten
das wird jetzt noch genau überprüft aber
es ist auf jeden Fall sicher da hat
nicht nur einer drohen wollen oder
irgendwie Leute erschrecken wollen da
steckt schon was hinter was weiß man
denn zu diesem Zeitpunkt immer mögliche
Täter es sind ja auch Hakenkreuze eben
auf diese Bomben gemalt worden
ja genau das ist auch der Hinweis den
die Polizei hat also man sieht auf jeden
Fall es sind Laien man hat sich offenbar
im Internet schlau gemacht und hat dann
irgendwas mit Pyrotechnik und
irgendwelchen Pulvern versucht
herzustellen aber das Hakenkreuz ist
natürlich ein ganz klarer Absender es
kann natürlich aber auch immer sein dass
so etwas ganz bewusst draufgemalt wird
um eine falsche Spur zu legen ein
Bekennerschreiben oder ähnliches ist
bislang jedenfalls nicht gefunden worden
und die Ermittlungen laufen jetzt auf
Hochton weil das wären neuartig in
Deutschland ist das noch nie gegeben das
rechtsradikal jetzt an irgendwelchen
Bahnhöfen plötzlich Bomben legen zwei
Rohrbomben mit Hakenkreuz in Erfurt
gefunden dazu unser bildschirmreporter
Frank Schneider danke dir für den Moment
gerne
[Musik]